[Music]
he's one of the most respected
scientists in the world he's published
over 700 peer reviewed articles he was
the longest serving chair of the Harvard
astronomy Department his interviews have
been seen by over 10 million people
worldwide but he remains controversial
so AI I get a little bit pissed off when
you throw the entire scientific culture
under the bus there has to be a
temptation to getting recognition I had
never heard of him until a few years ago
and now I hear about him constantly
today on the occasion of his second book
release Interstellar we take a deep dive
into his claims that he's discovered
evidence for
extraterrestrial technology and we'll
take on the critics attempting to answer
the most important question ever posed
are we
alone